good morning believe nation today's
messages have a structure over to you
Marcus lemonis so anytime I meet a
business owner of a small medium or
large business owner I really want them
to focus on three things people process
and product and you know we just talked
about people for a minute people are the
most important part of any business
that's the one part of the capital
structure that you need to have right
you need to have them incentivize with
the right pay plan they need to
understand they're important and quite
frankly you need to hire people that are
smarter than you when you move on to the
product side of things you want to make
sure that you have a product that's
relevant product or service that's
relevant that's priced properly that
that people actually want to come back
for and then lasts and maybe most
importantly from a cash perspective is
you want to have the right process in
place too often I'm finding people that
don't know their numbers and they don't
manage their cash and they don't manage
their expenses and so when I look at how
one of the reasons why businesses fail
is they don't have a good grasp on their
numbers they don't have a good grasp on
how much cash they have and how much
cash it takes to run a business so the
structure that Marcus uses is people
process product and that's what he looks
at every time he goes into a new
business do they have the people do they
have the process do they had a product
that's the lens that he looks at the
world through for me it's belief right I
make videos that are built believe I
attract clients who like the message of
believe I bring on teams and suppliers
who work with me who are about believe
that's the lens through which I see the
world what you want to do is find that
structure for yourself what is it that
you stand for what's really important
how do you evaluate opportunities and be
consistent and that allows you to be
true to yourself what I let you do is
one lets you make decisions more easily
faster and better decisions right if
something for Marcus if it has a bad
product or bad people or bad process
he's not going to invest for me if it's
working with someone who doesn't believe
and believe I'm not going to work with
them it makes decision-making so much
easier it also helps keep you motivated
in that you know you're doing something
important you know you have a system
that works and it can help keep you on
track and so I really encourage you guys
to have a structure a lens to which you
see the world because it'll make things
so much easier for your business so the
question today for you today is what's
the structure for you what's the lens to
which you see the world I'm really
curious to find out leave it in the
comments below and join in the
discussion
thank you so much for watching have an
amazing day continue to believe and I'll
see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot events Reza